all right we're here hello everyone
welcome to understanding practical chess
streams with guess who me tell you all
right so this is my first time with the
online class no I had that before
it's pretty cool anyway so today I
wanted to talk about again from my most
recent tournament IRA flood open in
Moscow it was a lot of fun always enjoy
going to Moscow for just related reasons
and that in this game I was kind of
looking forward for a win I was really
trying hard for a win because I had a
very good start of the tournament I I
think two and a half out of three on the
top section it was very very strong
start of the tournament but then I had I
think like three hundred three three out
of three out of seven which is not great
and I kind of wanted to pick myself back
up and it happened after this game and I
want a very nice game yes
Alexandra matza skya she's one of the
best female junior players in Russia
right now I've seen her a bunch of times
before but we actually played one time
before modules in 2018 so it was very
nice to get to play her again it was a
draw the game so I was looking forward
to win here despite being black pieces
alright so let's get on with the game I
think it involves a lot of tactical
decisions principles and good defense so
let's get to it d4 d5 c4 d take C for
the Queens gambit accepted very popular
nowadays very solid opening car wanna
[ __ ] wanna place a little bit
harikrishna
all the top guys you know are playing
this opening nowadays in the in the game
we had night of 3 which is the main line
but also just so you know a 4 is another
continuation a little more aggressive so
9 f3 Knight of 6 u 3e 6 I played I
played this way actually because it was
looking forward to Bishop c4 c5 Castle
knight c6 usually some time before 96 96
and a6 and since that's gonna be the
move order what you can do actually is
even after III play a 6 sometimes
opponents are too scared you know to
like a lot be sure before Bishop c4 b5
so they can play a 4 but this is
actually just a waste of temple it's not
necessary you don't play like Bishop
before if you want and this is fine so
it's like a little trick maybe it has
worked for me a few times but I played
with a 6 Bishop c4 c5 castle knight c6
this is an idea that I wanted to try out
I saw the game
Lissie versus efficient from the World
Cup 2019 couple of months ago very
efficient one and the game is very
nicely analyzed in American chess
magazine so you can check that out if
you want then look it up online black
one a very nice game and yeah so I
wanted to try that out
and here we are so Knight c3 a6 now we
have kind of transposed to the main
variation and hear my opponent place a3
a3 it's not a move that I knew at the
time by the way the list is shown game
continued with CD Queen D 1 rook to e1
Bishop c5 so that's completely different
that's carry into an endgame but besides
that also move to consider is maybe push
a veto just going back with the bishop
so if v doesn't come with the tempo and
for example if C d4 Knight the Forbush
of this famine night b3 completely
normal recent game from LMI versus time
forest from a topic so a3 a3 is not
actually a bad move at all the idea of
it is that if at some point black plays
C takes d4 after 8 x d4 we have got an
isolated pawn position and the point is
already on a3 so the bishop can come
back to a 2 whenever it needs to and
have ideas like wind III queen can be
one so for example I'll show ya
as well and maybe not now maybe like
Bishop g5 first or some other moves but
this is could be this is an idea and
also the opponent a3 prevents black from
going night before 95 which is a common
man either to play against the isolated
upon first you block it then your target
then you take it or in a more
complicated way which tends to happen a
lot
first you block it then you attack it
then you create a second witness and you
attack that second witness instead of
taking the isolated pawn in the first
place so you distract all of the pieces
from your opponent and then you come
back to the can be very tricky if it
wants to be so anyway a3 played b5 this
is the most logical continuation here
obviously there are options so for
example in the game my opponent went
Bishop 8 - but also Bishop d3 may have
been a possibility obviously is
something like this is not possible
something like this is not possible I
think we actually have some people in
the Chan I don't know if any of them
wanted it went to guess why but this
move is not good
how do you feel maybe a few moments
although it's not very hard
alright then so anyways yeah Bishop b5
we shall be 5 at the end wins
yeah night night takes a foreign Queen
sexy for Bishop we fight that's why
sometimes I wish upon d3 is not really
anything threatening because simply it's
not like black and take the pawn so yeah
we can continue Bishop e7 Bishop g5 and
this is just a standard isolated pawn
game which is something I was kind of
trying to avoid with my with my position
I thought that I could maybe try and get
something better than that
and usually I am on the side of the
isolated pawn not against it so I'm not
as comfortable playing those positions
and I also don't want to take on d4 if I
don't have to because I don't wanna open
the way for the c1 Bishop this is stock
already over there I don't really want
to do you know let the bishop come out
and be beautiful so after Bishop e2 we
should be seven Queen e2 Queen Susan
this all makes a lot of sense so far and
here for example the better continuation
would have been destroyed day one
directly Jewish the worse reply struck
the eighth and here there are actually
in this type of position there are
actually some ideas of d5 you'll get
that from the game later but don't if
you are playing on the black side of
this don't be worried because it's not a
huge deal I know sometimes when your
keys in the center and there is a pawn
break you know it can be completely
devastating but in this scenario is
completely fine because opponents on
history there is no open file here right
it's not like the Queen can just attack
the King on yet so you can just take
take play Bishop e7 and castle next move
don't really have to worry about this
because there are some tricks tricks are
for kids
yeah
and of course yeah the other in for
example in this game they play takes
takes but the idea of it is that for
example if Queen takes
b7 actually I'm gonna let you guess
first so clean text b7 what could
possibly happen
I think that our one move is better than
the other one
yeah there is one very good continuation
and some this is something also to keep
in mind during the Queen's Queen gambit
accepted variation sometimes you know
maybe like I supposedly hanging pawn on
the Queen side means you might get in
trouble in the center so try to guess
now how can black win the game
in this short line clean takes a 92
maybe I think it is possible but the
only my only worry is that after Queen
takes takes 97 there is king of one
after route takes cleantech c2 and you
get only two pieces for for the rook you
remember you're still one down right yes
so maybe try to change try to I would
say change the move orders but 92 is not
really the move but you know about it
yeah
Knight of three better yeah 99 of three
not of three is more solid well it's
just winning because you're forced to do
something about the King right if Bishop
takes rook takes t1 or Queen d7 both of
them are completely playable and if
context you work through the pins and
now your Bishop takes rook take c1 and
you're just winning by force so this is
a little example of how lines can get
very complicated in this type of
position and not always you know upon is
for free so that's important
anyway so in the position my opponent
played Bishop d2 actually which is a
much more passive move I had a similar
position that I was looking at earlier
today
and it's from a couple of months ago I
am Invitational here in November and
something similar happened I felt like
my opponent didn't actually know what to
do with their pieces and they just made
most like Bishop d2 d1 Greg c1 which is
actually fine in this scenario but in
the position that we had at the time it
wasn't however I can feel that you know
Bishop d2 is not really a move that you
want to make you you kind of want to
make specialist white you know more more
aggressive type of move so what do you
want would have been better although
official d2 is nothing out of the
ordinary
the the position is still about equal so
it's fine it's not like it's a bad move
that gives advantage to black right now
anyway so rook the 8th best continuation
you could argue for Bishop e7 but what I
didn't like what I was thinking in my
position was that I'm moving the bishop
and after it takes I have to move it
again so it's kind of like a ways to
move and after that Luke a c1 and the
Ruby is attacking both my bishop and the
Queen at the end of the of the file so
imagine doing this and then going back
to his I mean I move my bishop three
times so it's not it's not ideal Farouk
the 8th was better just bringing my
rogue into into the position and putting
pressure on d4 now let's say if Tom
takes
if context it's not actually an issue
anymore because I can just stick with my
bishop I only wasted one move in doing
so and if I need to apply my place my
bishop back on e7 or even d6 put my
bishop back on d6 get my queen to be one
out of any problems and have both pieces
you know attacking the the King sign
very active so Lucchesi one makes a lot
of sense once again playing on the x-ray
that we have in the C file and the best
move in the position was maybe just
simply taking on d4 actually takes and
playing Bishop e7 to get the one castle
this is once again an isolated position
although the pawn on d4 is being
attacked quite a quite a bit now by the
way not not Knight takes d4 maybe you
already you know figure out why but
Knight takes e4 let's suppose rook takes
before and obviously there'll be some
Knight takes d5 right
yeah so
[Music]
that's
Queen b6 is a move that I played in the
game and I kind of want to take a second
here to let you guys think the ones that
are watching and come up with a move for
white because in spite this being a
again you know sing from the black side
white had a very strong move here and
one that I didn't consider quite enough
and that I should have and it makes a
whole lot of sense because I haven't
finished my development and my
development making is not castle I just
moved my queen again which was not a
move I wanted to do in the game but I
thought that you know I'm moving my
Queen and the next move I get my wish
abandoned castle it will be fine so I
want to you know let you think for a
moment and come up with with the best
move for for the best for white
think about how you can create
initiative in the position playing on
the weaknesses of black house
now give you a hint for now for now and
for now the bishop 182 is very strong
yeah
d5 the fibers are very very very strong
move Moria you might think
just touch something so deep five
now what do what to take back with there
is only one good continuation out of the
many possible captures and by many
possible I mean Knight takes pawn takes
rook takes not really
and obviously the other option is moving
the night but that's just silly because
you context on c6 so what to do as black
the text if I would have been okay but
the five is more active and if they take
c5 just Bishop takes a path and that's
kind of what I want that's a reason why
I haven't been moving my bishop so yeah
think of a of the follow-up I'm just so
you know to be very careful so for
example if the e takes d5 you have to
consider if four and if Knight takes on
d5 you have to consider about ninety
five and Bishop defund Knight takes e5 I
guess so nothing opens up that's what I
was thinking in the game and that's why
I played Knight takes e5 however the
best move is taken with the pump best
move is taken with and after E for the
most challenging move from white not d5
this d5 sorry d4 is losing due to e5 and
this now has no squares to go to if
context takes and the King's in a lot of
trouble so
the best move is he takes e4 Knight
takes e4 Knight takes e4 queen takes e4
Bishop e7 and the next move is Castle
castle as quick as possible and things
will start getting back into place 95 is
not great first of all you can take on
on d2 but maybe even better
c4 blocking the bishop and no more
chances of place against f7 definitely
not cosmo this of Queen takes H them so
yeah this would have been about equal so
after Luke ce-1 Castle 95 takes takes
rook c8 and you might look a little bit
uncomfortable for black because they
have a they have kind of like the Kings
side a little bit lonely but we have a
pawn more and also right now I guess of
discovery or happened like 94 and maybe
bring the Queen to the Kings side and
yeah so instead of that instead of done
I played 90 85
now Knight takes e5 is a mistake it's a
mistake and I didn't actually realize it
during the game of course otherwise I
wouldn't have play Knight takes e5 but
trying to figure out what to capture
with Knight takes d5 for Bishop takes d5
we'll give you a few moments this is
really messy and it's really tough to to
you know keep calm while cleaning black
in this position well kept me calm was
that my opponent was spending a lot of
time and for some reason I had this
feeling that it wasn't really gonna work
out I didn't actually play it right but
my feeling was kind of right okay so
we're getting a few suggestions here and
both of them are Knight takes e5 I'll
allow you know finish my my my
explanation and then I'll go back into
the line so be quick to leave your
comments if you are thinking about it
you think so too
alright I finish my comment and then
we'll move on to the game I don't want
to keep you waiting for to them oh we
have finally one comment with bishop
takes d5 whoa Stanislav
trying to learn Russian anyway so right
so I was saying I during this tournament
what I could tell that was you know how
I could tell that I was in good form
because in general I wasn't good for me
beat two genomes hundred rating points
what I could feel was that I was playing
based on instinct and I had a good
feeling about my moves and I played with
confidence and I for some reason I
wasn't too worried here and I lost a
little bit of that confidence while
playing in the middle rounds of the
tournament but during this game I could
kind of feel what was happening so final
reveal the correct continuation is
actually Bishop takes e5 Bishop takes e5
the reason why it's so good that it is
there after text if for now there'll be
a great outpost for the knight on d5 for
example D form probably the most logical
move 9527 97 probably looking to move
and then just simply Knight back and why
it has a clear advantage another move 97
this takes everything rocks III with the
idea of rock III and once again clear
advantage
and the last move t-take see for now
this is what I missed
I only consider quintics efore and I
thought 97 I'm fine
however white has Knight takes e4 and
this is very uncomfortable because after
Bishop e7 Knight takes e5 and after a
castle there are some ideas of 90 727
Brooks c6 takes Queen sexism and it
leads to better play for white so yeah
that good job to those who recommended
Bishop takes d5
okay so let's get back here now Knight
takes d5 is what happened in the game
and after text before the move that I
saw a lot of people were recommending in
the chat the best continuation is d4 you
really want to do something like takes
this is kind of like suicide almost
because you're opening up the way for
the bishop
and lots of ideas are happening right
now
for example twin takes 97 now they can't
play for f7 maybe something like Queen
Queen to f4 could be putting pressure on
the pond the the problem is that this
Queen if it comes to f3 and to have 6 it
loses control of c5 so it's kind of like
everything it's a it's a mess here
anyways just in general also their
specialty fire in general don't don't
don't open up the position when your
king is in the center so best move is d4
now black actually has a better position
black has a better position
and let me show you one so really
quickly if Bishop d5 Bishop e7 95 castle
Queen h5 there's no issue with us we can
just stay taken place see four and this
is completely fine and now the key move
Knight g5 Knight g5 now there are two
obvious ways white black and protect f7
which is the main threat Omega I was for
it
f7 is the main threat there are two ways
what can a black and defend from those
one is better than the other one not
really huge difference both are winning
for not winning but maybe clearly better
for black and I'll show you so let's
start with the variation which is c4 c4
is actually maybe a little bit better
than the other move but whether what I
didn't like from it was Knight takes f7
now 90 xf7 there is only one good
continuation so I'll let the chat
actually never mind
Knight takes f7 context of 7 how should
white continue if King takes f7
what
what could be the placement from for
white also you know when you're you know
before c4 you have to see this one and
you have to analyze and you know it's
not easy you know seeing all of these
lines but if you're actually just in
front of the board and you're looking at
all of these long calculations that are
actually accurate and you're seeing you
know all of the threats your opponent
has and you're like wow I'm actually you
start feeling like so you know so
powerful to like you're actually in good
form to to calculate and set up traps
for your opponent and realizing the the
traps that your opponent is setting up
for you so after a king takes f7 there
is one very strong move from from white
anybody has any ideas obviously you have
to be very active because you already
gave up a knight so
ooh lots of comments getting in right so
for in this position
Ruth takes a fire it's very dangerous
white is actually winning in this wine
the idea sort of context
Quinn takes let's say q7 cleany six you
need clean up some and can you six once
again clean up some and this is not
pleasant
black would have to play through the
fire but you know this is just silly
there's no need to get into this however
however after 907 the strong move is
defined III in the intermediate move now
after a queen of three let's say 94
Queen h5g 625 takes rook takes e4 it
doesn't actually work now first of all
I'll comment this there is special you
seven this idea
but rook takes before doesn't actually
work yes takes takes Knight d6 Queen
takes Queen c6 and black is a piece more
and there they have clear advantage you
guys think how complicated this game was
I would have never been able to sing
this variation so I play 95 95 and 95 is
supported by some trick some tricks yeah
you would actually want to suck the rook
because I feel like the bishop is much
more valuable on the a to f7 a to g8
diagonal and if you are going to
sacrifice something you know sorry
professor Luke might as well since you
know it's what's gonna help keep the
initiative so here my opponent played f4
I was considering Bishop before but
thought that Queen f6 was just fine for
me because I'm attacking the bishop the
bishop has to keep defending the knight
on d5 so let's say it takes I can take
here and I'm fine my next move my next
few moves are we should be so in castle
finally so yeah Bishop a4 is not a big
problem the key move is f4 now what to
do against f4 there is only one move
this game was tough really tough and
we're spending a lot of time I can't
take it I can't tell you exactly you
know how much time we were spending but
maybe by this point we both had a half
an hour and what I was trying to do is
since I knew my position was less
complicated than my opponents I didn't
know if I was completely winning or not
I didn't see a good move for white by
the way think about the position while
I'm talking there's only one good move
here for white for black sorry what was
I saying right so what I was trying to
do is since we both had about half an
hour and it was her turn to make a move
first after the one I did now I was
trying to make tough decisions to make
her get quicker into time pressure so
about other half an hour mark I would
start playing more practical chess and
kind of let my opponent you know think
forever never play of six that's true f6
here it's a big no-no opening up the
diagonal for the bishop even more the
sister disaster
maybe the three a lot of people are
recommending the three let's see d3
these three how about this way how about
I guess coinage five maybe suppose
ability logistics I don't like so much
although I guess maybe clean each tree
is a possibility I was thinking more of
clean of two actually what are you going
to defend this pond now maybe maybe this
but minimum I think I can suck it change
this is this doesn't look good for this
doesn't look good for for black how
about you you change the move orders how
about you change the move orders instead
of these three to the other move I'm
guessing you're realizing now what I
mean
let's go back to the to the position so
you can see clearly here
you are mentioned in d3 now change the
move orders
all right nobody has a clue
remember you second move first and then
the first move second there's nothing to
worry about it's an explosive move some
would say
right see far way no not nice it for us
see for actually
I think the idea of this ring 94 is a
little bit slow
yeah c4c everybody is now realizing who
yeah C 4 C 4 is the only move and it's a
decisive move that gives black the
complete advantage you had to see C 4
before playing 95 so yeah
c4 of course if F takes D 3 clean up to
Bishop c5 and if what I was gonna do we
should be three takes takes takes with
check and after rook takes we can play
route d7 and this Bishop on on a 2 that
is to be so good it's not very bad we
are an exchange up the pawn on f7 is
protected next move is h6 the double
points on the center are not good and
the position is winning okay so we know
that F takes e5 is not possible
therefore white needs to do something
else but they're kind of running out of
things to do so by the way I calculated
this line during the game I think it was
officially fine I think I calculated
Bishop a5 during the game but just
thought Queen a7 Bishop takes d3 once
again because what I don't want to do is
I don't want to allow Queen a5 I think I
don't want to allow this to happen
so my opponent plays Queen h5 but after
Queen h5
okay I have a question that if okay I
have a question that if here
I think they saw Bishop d3 but I think
you mean Bishop III I'm sorry chef III I
can use taken the Queen's thing is so
pinned you don't have time to do this
see because it's been so yeah I think
that's what you mean
yeah it's so loose is the Queen
unfortunately so it's a very beautiful
calculation yeah okay so they played
Queen h5 she put a queen h5 and I play
Queen e6 I think we need 6 is better
than Queen g6 simply we goes after Queen
h6
you can't take because I take with I
took here right away yeah so also you
know in general I have two points two
central pawns the bishop on an a2 is
kind of bad so getting into something
like this it's not really a big deal for
me because now we have what 4 + 2 6 4
same amount of bones but the opponent's
on and they e-file are gonna fall and
the bishop on a2 is bad and I have one
pass sleep and I was completely fine
with getting into this hanging so Quinn
do you want but now that position is
just simply winning simply winning after
we shall be soon we shall be 7 obviously
can't take only 5 can't take only five
because Bishop g5 is coming and there is
no follow-up I'm gonna cause some next
move so
that's very very strong like I'll show
you
Thanks and castles and it's completely
fine finally got something I move 22
yeah so my opponent instead of doing
done Maeda I think what was a worse move
983 but she she kept the spirit of
trying to fight for something even if
you know this is objectively a worse
option than trading pieces she's still
trying to get pieces on the board to
have some sort of you know trick in the
future I think about here maybe she had
seven minutes I had a little bit more
like 20 something and we do in this
tournament it was one round per day so
we did get an extra 30 minutes after
move 40 but we don't move 20 so there's
no way like she'll have to play you know
really fast just to get to there and she
didn't actually make it to move 40 in
this game so afternoon RH 393 very
obvious move rook c2 and actually I felt
like I was I could Castle here for sure
but I felt like I was good good to play
Bishop takes e4
why because after my I can play at five
if I choose to what's your opponent
worse than you actually no she was
higher writer than me she wasn't maybe
she was about the writing that I have
now she was she was I think 23 14 about
there and my random right now is 2311
the thing is that I went from $21.99 to
twenty-three-eleven
in one tournament just because I had
very very strong result so
yes it was a big jump although Iranians
were very different I did feel like I
was strong enough to beat my opponents
even with the black pieces simply
because I played her before and I felt I
don't know I had I had this feeling I
actually did castle in the game don't
worry i actually castled well we'll get
to there this is supposed to be
practical chess and I'm teaching I'm
teaching you not to castle whatever what
am i doing anyways so let's get on with
the with the game like I was saying I
felt like I was good to take on you for
because I have had five necks in the
worst case scenario so Bishop a5 rook d7
b3 trying to open things up and just one
final thing that I want to that I want
to address don't don't try to don't
don't play really fast even when you are
winning when you see that you have a
winning position I'm not telling you to
spend all of your time because that's
also very bad but try to find the
continuation that gives less that gives
less you know chances for your opponent
so
okay
made c5 my idea was you know the
discovery of the bishop and my opponent
played B takes c4 which was a huge
surprise to me I thought she was gonna
play Rudy too but after up d2 there is
c3 rook takes c4 c2 attacking the Queen
so you don't have time to take on this
722 rook checks before Queen takes e4
and finally the move that you have all
been waiting for Castle so yeah that was
a variation I was calculating and this
is completely winning for for black like
I have a pawn in the seventh rank this
is just a strong pair of bishops this is
just crashing cool so it's not she
played beat exit for Bishop sexy to
clean taxi - finally finally the big
move
Castle castle Ino moved 25 I don't know
how to feel about it don't know how to
feel about it anyways so
[Music]
yeah I don't know what I can say about
living on the edge but in this game I
did live on the edge also you know I was
I was you know kind of going downhill a
little bit in the tournament so I really
want needed something to pick myself
back up and I thought why not play super
aggressive beautiful game actually that
there was none of my intent I was
planning on playing a very solid game
and see what I can get with the black
pieces against her but I also had a lot
of confidence so I was getting into all
of this months you know without without
doubting myself much so with Citrix we
fight we'll see how the game finishes
and a b5 Bishop before d3 quindi won
Queen f6 Queen b6 was also a possibility
here okay so clean up 695 clean before
was another move doing this I was
considering but I didn't find it
necessary I just played h6 no Knight to
f3 94 now with some really big threats
can anybody tell me what's the biggest
red black house in this position maybe
some some you know weak dark squares
actually this position is just a
completely winning so I can do anything
I want
almost and get away with it but you know
always making threats so the life
squares are very weak here in one
specific diagonal I'm guessing you mean
couldn't be six yeah Queen b6 Queen b6
is a big threat here cool so my opponent
played g3 Bishop takes before maybe four
D to Quincy to rook f d8 also do you one
was winning I think I don't remember
exactly how the line went but I think
it's something like this maybe
in tech square too
anyways I put look at the eight queen
takes e4 do you want simply and
unfortunately my opponent thought the
I'm guessing they were trying to fight
for you know the best continuation and
maybe you know whatever gave them the
biggest chance but they applied we
should be one which you know it's not
that you should reply to a queen
promotion but you know maybe she was
trying to make it to move forty and
although I mean it this is just very
this is just very very very lost
I think computer might be given mate by
this point yeah anyways so we should be
one Queen b6
kingi to and finally just ripped it to
after rook to Knight takes I can take
with rook Queen here Queen h5
should we check my and not given a
single chance even for a queen h7 check
so yeah that's how the game finished I
actually I'll put the final position
final position was this one
yeah so this is how the game finished I
was actually extremely pleased with my
results game didn't even last so long
maybe like two or three hours so I felt
very good you know beating my opponent
in such a short amount of time for a one
round and a tournament the tournament's
are long you interview real I said you
know like you should I start at 3 p.m.
one time I had around that lasted up
until 8:00 so maybe even later I've had
nine and a half hour game so 125 moves
these tournaments are long so anything
like 2 3 hours is actually pretty good
in general especially with the 3 minutes
at the end so this felt very nice I felt
like I was getting myself back up and
this was around 8 actually so I won
round 8 had 4 out of 8 and I went on to
the last round against a fellow master
actually we still have some extra time
so I can set up a position from that
game or like show that the final part of
it anyway so cool to have a such a sharp
gaming and fast well generally and game
games that are sharp and up faster
and you know it's it's you already know
this but it's very double-edged so like
not only can you lose not only can you
win very fast you can also lose very
fast and despite the game being really
fast your calculation has to be very
precise to allow yourself to actually
find the correctness because there were
a few times in this position in this
game where I had to find the only move
like for example c4 it was a very nice
move
c4 was a very nice move queening 6 was
another very nice move earlier I had to
find exe file instead of Knight takes a
fact that was an only move too so yeah
it's important to to always you know try
to be as sharp as possible and yeah
alright so since we have a few more
minutes
maybe I will set up maybe I'll set up a
position from the game really quickly
since it's from the last round so I can
explain you know like transition from
round 8 to round 9 in ROM and I was
playing a feeling master that I have
seen on many tournaments in Russia
before but never actually played very
strong player of course 2300 I think he
was we the game was a sandwich variation
and then we I actually felt like I had a
good position for the whole game but you
know time pressure does its things and
he actually had a lot of
a lot of counter play right so this is
the position I'll flip the board and as
you can probably guess why this an
exchange down
why doesn't exchange down actually I
think I need to make this so it's oops I
need to make this so it's black
now here we both have like about a
minute my opponent who could have played
Bishop f5 which is a move that I missed
I missed action actually I set up from
here this was a position so my best move
was Quincy one and here maybe I am
winning however I made a mistake I play
Queen h4 on time pressure and mr. after
Bishop f5 can't take because of this
roof after rooty eight they have King
King f8 and I have no way to get out of
this handling pin I found a route d8
work because after takes takes Queen
afraid I can take and take here and
that's what I had in mind
minimum they don't really realize bishop
takes a five until the game was in front
of me so but anyways my opponent made a
big mistake a player takes beat you
now with any of your other I like to
guess how to continue as white
and they move I made I didn't know if it
was the best or not but I knew I was
very trippy I thought maybe I was
missing something I didn't have much
time to think but the move I did just
now it was very tricky and really I said
it will be tough to make a move for my
opponent I ended up winning this game
112 rating points and and I think I got
I got the best female prize although
there were females ahead of me but I got
placed 36 and they gave Crysis 2 1 to 35
so technically I got best female price
because I got 36 and I was like
literally the only the next person right
out of the top 35 and by the way I got
36 place but on the ranking I was 92 so
that's very that's very nice so we have
Krug d3f 6 we have 2 votes for each it's
somebody comment gonna comment and break
the tie one is better than the other
I'll say done
so they're saying F 6:20 6:53
now touch sleeping
f6
of six what if what if Queen age seven
playing g5 Clin here I think the only
issue with queen with f6 is that it
gives me a free temple that's black
maybe it still works
but I think maybe it still works but I
think maybe there is a more precise way
to to continue and that more precise way
to continue is actually with fruit III
now the most important thing about fruit
d3 is what happens if Queen takes c3
what happens if Queen takes c3 can you
take it back it's a free Queen you never
know
do you have any ideas of what to do you
mind my checks captured and threats
always
let's see have to wait a little bit
because I feel like it's all over
delayed that should chat with the stream
I'm very proud of this game too because
in general it was very nicely played
maybe could have given my opponent less
chances throughout the whole game
Oh Lewis just will be saying Queen g5
unfortunately after 25 after 25 the
Queen can go backwards
there's Queen g7 and we just lost peace
for no reason
however the other move that was
commented what's better fruit III Rocky
III is better now if Queen takes we take
with Shaq so I don't have time to make a
background check mate and if King f8
Queen h6g 3 Queen d6 is checkmate so
like is loosing after proved g3 anyways
to finish it off there is not much to do
my opponent maybe had a minute to try to
figure things out and he couldn't he
played king of fate because I don't
think there's a way to figure things out
like if for example Queen hg3
King h8 26 pretty nice so he played King
f8 and now the move that you all wanted
to do never play never play never play 1
what move we should never played unless
we have to play
it's kind of like training the move
orders once again all right Oscar
let's curtiss-wright f6
and there's nothing to do in the game
that he continued with queen g6 queen a
trade queen g8 queen h6 and hear me
resigned because you know there's
nothing racist indeed anyways so in this
position there is just nothing left to
the Queen g7 Queen takes g7 and it's
checkmate so very simple
yeah so that's how my last game finished
both games were very aggressive towards
the end so I guess what we can learn
from today was best defenses
counter-attack don't take too long to
Castle and try to find yeah try to find
the most active counter play keep in
mind you know long diagonal bishops yeah
this is the payoff of doing tactics
looks like c4 in the first game so yeah
I hope you guys enjoy the little game I
had planned today alright so thank you
for coming home watching keep watching
all of the videos and the San Luis
Cheska will be posting all the lectures
and live streams look out for my live
streams I live stream quite a bit
especially on Thursdays ladies play the
people so yeah I hope you enjoyed this
game and motivated you to do more chess
and I'll see you next time good bye